does it bother you that you didn't get
Rookie of the Year nah didn't bother me
I blame myself
y'all circles floats and hits but okay
honestly after that first game and you
said it's over did you feel so silly Oh
trust me trust me I always see what's up
everybody is trained young here with the
Atlanta Hawks and your girl here is back
in a town and I know she got a lot of
questions for me so we've got to take it
there with Taylor rooks trailer my
goodness straight in the bag drink
quickly thank you for spending time with
me after practice back home be here what
she says may be fun are you loving
Atlanta I love it a lot of times people
say like you are the star Atlanta needs
what do you think they mean when they
say that about you
I mean that excitement that kind of buzz
a national attention and I just think
they need someone to come in bring that
fire back I can see if Atlanta how wild
is it though to think like if you
continue this trajectory that you're at
right now like your name is with the
Dominique's yeah this is crazy
it's crazy to think sometimes it's like
I look up at the rafters like and on and
on generally pistol PC Dominique you see
legends and then people tell me all the
time if I stay healthy and things go my
way and continue this way that one day
my Jersey could be hanging out there now
it is no secret anybody follows me knows
I go very hard for the Hawks I am hot
spirit the thing though that whenever
talked about the Hawks people are like
they're losing
you're not even that good I'm like we're
young like we're figuring it out but how
long can were young be an excuse for
losing not very long
not very long I think you look at our
team though we've started five guys 22
and younger so it's not excused by any
means but it's just reality be honest
with you trust me a little change soon
so let's talk about draft night
obviously that is a night that is going
to stay with you forever
give me a play-by-play of how the day
and night happens I remember looking on
TV just wanted to see what people were
thinking about where I was gonna go and
I was like everyone's gonna go 12 14 and
I was talking about a just really you
just turn off everything get to the
draft sitting down at the table third
piece about to get caught it's Atlanta
the Commission comes out and they say
look at dawn shave with the third pick
so as to be walking across the stage my
dad sitting next to me of my agents
right behind me they come up and they
say you're going to Atlanta so what'd
you mean they didn't like they didn't
just call me I didn't know to write
there but all day my dad and my agent
they knew that they were going to trade
up for me and I was still confused
and so my hands were sweating so hard
when the fourth pick got called Memphis
was called and I was like crying like I
was like nervous didn't know how I was
gonna be I didn't want to trip up the
stairs going up and then they announced
my name and then I got across the stage
got down thoughts of Maria Taylor and
she was just telling me they're just
trading me to Atlanta when you look at
that night are you like okay I wish they
would have told me earlier in the day
are you happy with how it I'm happy with
how I'm gonna have you at that happen I
think my father no maybe I wouldn't have
been so nervous but I don't think I
would have really appreciated the moment
dan so it's cool you know if I was you I
would be so annoyed with the constant
Luke trait on just because you're going
to be tied forever and I mean I don't
know if you can really help it but does
it bother you that that's what it's
always going to be I mean to be honest
with you like it's annoying but it's
gonna be it's gonna be I wait so we're
both we're both dumb plans tomorrow I'll
just embrace it
[Applause]
with the white basketball has evolved
should we move the three-point line I
think maybe we should add to change the
game up a little bit and the way guys
are hitting half-court shots making that
four points maybe I'd be cool does it
bother you that you didn't get Rookie of
the Year
no I didn't bother me it doesn't bother
me too much I blame myself for not
getting Ricky of the year I didn't put
myself in the best situation early on
the way I started and I came on super
hot late but it was already too late I
mean so for me I can't really be mad at
anybody besides myself no I will say
obviously I follow a lot of hawks people
on Twitter your first year there were
some shaky moments and there was a lot
of people that were like alright shoulda
got Luka yeah what did you think when
that was happening this way just gonna
change is gonna is gonna be better you
and I had my struggling moments I think
everybody really really overreacted time
about I didn't shoot very well my first
game and it was all on sports than at
all everybody could talk about all
sports channels is just I mean how major
of a bus I could be I just took it with
a grain of salt and just wanted people
to keep that same energy when it turned
over so that's how I looked at it your
iconic tweet of course was the apology
should be as loud as a disrespectful
business have the apologies been as loud
they were they're allowed it's never
gonna be 100% people on your side why is
there a game for you were you like this
is it this is the turning point we
played in Denver and some guys out
whenever our third best player got hurt
John was out for me to go off in Denver
against a really good team and get a win
on the road I think that was like one of
those moments
all right I can do this you do have some
vets on this team but it's not like you
have a super strong vet Corps presence
on this team who do you lean on in the
NBA guys like Chris Paul he's growing up
going to Thunder games I've known you
talk to to KD Russ those are my guys my
guy that can really I can call taught to
ask for advice what is the best piece of
advice that Chris Paul has given you
stay aggressive he I'm about to be
played them last year in my Riccio just
I played really well out there and you
just he wants me to succeed to be
aggressive just always be in attack mode
and one just two scores to be attack
mode to get other people involved
whatever it was and what's the best use
of device that was the Westbrook has
given Russell's giving me a lot of
advice over the years I remember when I
was a kid I was going to a Thunder game
he walked out with some crazy clothes on
which he always does but I asked him
about some some clothes he had on these
and maybe one day you can get some of
these it was I think at the time it was
christened like blue buttons and there's
some spiked shoes with the red bottoms
and so I'll never forget that and I
think after we put him this year he was
telling about his his first year in the
league
they lost 27 games in a row so it's like
just to stay with it be that leader on
my team
[Applause]
kind of a debate around because the
Hawks are a losing team I even got into
a fight about this on Twitter so that's
different Ori what should be the
criteria of being an all-star I've
always been taught winters care of
everything so my main focus coming to a
seasons winning but I think with this
year's criteria people are mad but I was
first in fan voting I was second and the
media and then I was third in peers so
it's like I don't know what people I
should be mad about tell me your
favorite all-star moment that we don't
know about
Oh favorite all-star moment I mean I
think people saw me in Yanis I was
talking about he'd be traveling and and
all this stuff on his euros and I
thought he picked up the ball before he
took his his deputies left foot and then
he take a gyro it's quick but like
whenever he demonstrates it to you
slowly you understand why it's not that
woman
nutmeg time you learn the nutmeg I was
uh I always I do it with my dad messing
around or whatever he would always do it
on me so do you play defense right I
always got to relax you hankie not up
but I'm I'm out here I'm up here I'm up
here you got it I didn't also a game
with James did but you did like a it was
crazy turn so here so I was driving
subject gardening huh sorry no don't do
it that's how I got the layup and it's
funny because I even when you did it to
James you nutmeg and then he tries they
like do this but it's too late before
you realize it okay anybody you want a
nutmeg that you haven't yet won a nutmeg
I think people are seeing it coming now
but I probably the best
pretty cool I know you're cooking some
stuff up in the kitchen right now that
you want to try yeah give me a little
taste like what you're trying to what
some new moves well there was a move I
did in high school it's all that
three-point line I did this most of the
time I took a dribble can you ever be an
elite defender at your size yes and for
me being that it's not gonna be a Pat
Bev type of defender it's gonna be elite
as far as just keeping my man from out
of the paint being sneaky with steals
being like a Chris Paul type of a
defendant being like a pest
[Applause]
50 points
[Applause]
so career-high 50 points boughs
fantastic congrats to you appreciate it
you got the last laugh the Miami Heat
okay what was going on between you and
Jimmy throughout that game any trash
talk
no way no trash talking wouldn't haven't
said just just two competitive guys
going at it but okay honestly after that
first game when you said it's over did
you feel so sick
Oh trust me trust me I would see ya I
was sick I was uh when I said it was
over we were up by six and I got taken a
minute left you got taken out you got a
good shot off
they cannot hit three and tied it and I
was like oh my gosh and I knew if we
didn't win that game people were going
to talk about that for a long time and
so yeah fast for and everybody was
talking about it for a long time
all-time three-point contest you can
pick three players staff for being there
Reggie Miller would be in there and
probably Ray Allen okay right now you
get to make this dream team and give me
current players or past players your
starting five your the starting point
guard okay tell me the dream for around
you dream for at my to guard
I want Kobe my three I would put LeBron
at my four I would put kd5 who is the
hardest player to defend in the league
there's so me carry fry the toughest
chiropractor just getting so shifty the
score you can even just a play so it's
probably prank I true or false and why
you are afraid of birds
oh very true I just had crazy dreams as
a kid trying to figure out what I would
do if it attacked me so for me I'm
extremely afraid of birds
what do you come up with how the how'd
you get it off slappy ha ha true or
false and why'd you should make the
final Olympic roster false my team my
time will come as far as making the
final 12 I think true I should have been
on the list of the people that he's got
to go out into training camp 244 I don't
think I should be on the final roster I
think those guys that those 12 guys are
the bronzes desk I mean I think it's
their time to keep it going so my time
will come okay last segment I do this
think on on this day you posted so I'm
gonna show you a post okay you're gonna
tell me why you post it what you were
thinking what's going through your mind
I only have one for you you ready I'm
ready
you are close now oh no I think I was
gonna do what it is okay you ready not
this video this same is and I got the
head on right now I'm kind of an
attorney about to turn it back this is
nice this is not right all right turn it
out I don't know it's crazy right
this crazy against came here I was a
think I may have been an eighth grader
oh yeah I'm sure I think I was an eighth
grader maybe a ninth grader
I don't know why I don't know if I sent
it to my girlfriend back then or what I
did and as I yeah
and now let's prep now this forever so
the internet that's the lesson that kids
can learn
don't ever post something because you
may regret someday it's not terrible
there's worse things it's just so me
mobile yeah always put it up any time
you do anything it'll be me forever
thanks for having back in Atlanta pretty
good time you have a great all right
thank you
[Music]
hey guys it's Taylor Oakes thank you so
much for watching my show take it there
but now that means you have to subscribe
to the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss all the fun stuff or the next
interview so hit that subscribe button
thanks so much see you soon